hey guys Pete here long time no see
maybe we'll get into that later for now
we have some pretty interesting stuff
that came out for Game of Thrones this
week we got our first non spoilery ish
Season seven photos and even though we
saw most of this stuff if you've been
following my channel in previous videos
I'm not going to go into the spoilers we
know they're going to happen I'm just
going to talk about these photos as they
are there are light productions spoilers
here so if you don't want to know
anything about the season before you go
into it then you're not going to want to
watch otherwise this is all good so we
got 15 photos in total and the first one
is with Queen Cersei on the Iron Throne
and the red keep with her brother Jaime
standing nearby I think the first thing
that stands out about this photo is the
look on Jamie's face he's obviously in
the show at least still dedicated to
Cersei and their relationship but he
doesn't look completely at ease I would
say you know whenever he's standing next
to her she looks clean like and she has
her new outfit on which we saw on one of
the promos that came out a few weeks ago
and we could see that she sort of has
this spiky collar around her neck which
is kind of could be some foreshadowing
towards things to come also we saw this
before but we do see that he has widow's
wail on his hip so he's carrying
Valyrian steel even though he gave
Brienne his Oathkeeper blade in the next
photo we get Lyanna Mormont who's played
by Bello Ramsay she's wearing furs it's
cold in the north and we've got
Littlefinger hiding in the background
I mean he's not hiding but he's you know
he's just sort of lurking there this is
not from last season this is a new photo
so let's hope that we'll get more action
from her and we'll get another shot of
Littlefinger before the whole thing is
over next up we have Davos he's sitting
at the main table in Winterfell and this
is no big surprise we knew he's Jon's
main advisor for the most part he's
sitting there he's looking out at
someone we don't know who and this could
really be a lot of different things so
there's not really much to speculate
here but we know that Davos is still
going to be giving sound advice so far -
Jon Snow in the next season the next
shot is probably was the most
interesting to me we see Sam
and Gili inside the citadel from what we
can tell and she's reading a piece of
paper where the text is actually clear
where we could see what it was
now I doomed it on this and I could make
out a few things but actually someone on
reddit realized this is an excerpt from
the world of Ice and Fire so we actually
know what it says reddit user its JRR
realize that it's this particular
passage from the world of Ice and Fire
with only one small change it reads it
is also written that there are annals
and a sigh of such a darkness and a of a
hero who fought against it with a red
sword his deeds are said to have been
performed before the rise of Illyria in
the earliest age when old gifts was
first forming its Empire this legend has
spread west from a shy and the followers
of roll or which has been changed here
in the show to the Lord of Light claim
that this hero was named azor Ahai and
prophesy his return in the Jade
compendium koloko wrote our recounts a
curious legend from UT which states that
the Sun hid its face from the earth for
a lifetime ashamed that something none
could discover and that disaster was
averted only by the deeds of a woman
with a monkey's tail so she's learning
about prophecy specifically related to
soar high which if you're familiar with
the books if you're a book reader you
know there's other different legends
from different parts of the world but
what does it all mean I mean I think
this is a definite nod especially since
they're letting us see the paper and
know what it says that we're going to
find out more about as or high with
Melisandre maybe being sidelined so far
this may be a backdoor to the red God
influence over the situation if Sam and
Kelly finds something here or learn
something here that will lead them to
John or generics or whatever so this
could keep up the influence that the
Lord of Light has on the story
if Melisandre isn't around as much as we
have been used to in the next photo we
see Meera kind of struggling to pull
brands you know they're kind of on their
own now that Hodor has sacrificed
himself and it looks like they're sort
of looking up and people have speculated
I kind of want to
want this to be true myself that they
may be finally seen Castle black in the
wall after journeying through the snow
so let's I mean that's the best we can
hope for here and I think there's a
pretty good chance that that's what's
going on in the next photo we get a
little bit of fanservice
at the very least with poor moon kind of
giving a loving or at least interested
look in Brienne who probably if we could
see her face wouldn't be so interested I
don't think that anything is really
going to come out of this other than a
little bit of comedy from time to time
because it seems pretty obvious that
Brienne has a thing for Jamie and Jamie
is not going to necessarily get away
from Cersei I don't think either way
tormund is a fun character and you know
it's kind of funny that he seems to be
interested in Brienne who as you can see
in the photo is much taller than him
which is kind of funny also from there
we have a photo of Littlefinger who
obviously looks to be scheming but it's
also actually looks like in the photo
that she's not really under his spell
maybe be the way to describe it
we know that Littlefinger is always
looking out for his best interest here
he could be trying to turn her against
Jon turn her against the idea of him
being king in the north
or it could have something to do with
some of the other spoilery stuff he got
in some of the old videos like I said
I'm not going to go into all that stuff
but if you want to I have a playlist
with all the pre-production spoilers
we've had and we definitely talked about
a situation that could be related to
this photo right here we also got a
picture of the Hound on horseback
wearing some fur and he's in smell the
last time we saw him he was in the
Riverlands and this could be that I mean
we expect that winter will spread
throughout Westeros this year but it's
more likely that they're actually
heading north like what he said we'll
just have to wait and see where this
scene takes place once season seven
comes out then we get king of the north
Jon Snow in his new armor covered with a
fur the general consensus and the fandom
is that this is inside the Winterfell
crypts that could actually be exciting
for a number of reasons we don't really
know why he's down there in the first
place probably for Rickon or maybe he's
you know he went down to see Ned's
resting place or something like
but some people have speculated that he
may be looking at the Statue of Lyanna
stark which would be his mother now the
look on his eye he looks sad and that
doesn't mean that he knows that his
mother at this point but many people are
theorized for a long time that he was
going to find out about his parentage in
the crypts or from something in the
crypts so this could be a really big
scene or at least the start of something
that will end up in him finding out
whether it be through bran or through a
item that's in the crypts that gives
them a clue as to who his true parents
actually are the final stark we get a
picture of is aria and I have no idea
where she's at it looks like it's
probably an inn if you look at the table
behind there's people drinking there it
doesn't look like the twins it looks
like a public place so we're going to
assume that she left there which we all
expect her to do anyway so we don't
expect you to spend the whole of season
seven and the twins so this could be on
route nor she could stop at an inn
Watchers on the wall mentioned that she
might be in Riverrun although I don't
think it looks like a castle but it
could be I mean we know that there's a
good chance that she's going to free
Edmure this season so you know her Uncle
Ed in here so she could be there what's
interesting about this photo is as if
you zoom in you can kind of see a
reflection of someone in her eyeball so
the look on her face is in relation to
that person but there's no way to tell
who exactly it is just by looking at
this picture but we'll find out what's
going on with it whenever we finally get
to that from there we go to Targaryen
camp and we get a picture of Danny and
her Targaryen colors finally we know
from the trailer and from some other
things that she's probably in the throne
room at Dragonstone and she's like I
said everyone's pretty excited to see
her wearing the Targaryen colors black
and red we also got a picture of Varys
here and he's actually wearing a fur so
if you look at the second picture he's
wearing something different so it's not
exactly clear where this is actually
happening at we have Masson Dee she is
wearing her new outfit and tyrion with
his hand of the Queen with his hand pin
there let me get a shot of them all
together in
grey worm again this is most likely at
Dragonstone which will be her seat when
she finally arrives in Westeros it's her
family house and if you haven't seen it
I have a video all about it so you can
check that out but that's about it for
this so I mean I'm sure you guys have
seen the the long walk promo which
didn't give up a lot other than you know
we got to see these outfits once already
plus the little promo where they had all
the different shots of them in their new
gear so what do you think does this give
anything away to you guys we still have
like 80 some days until season 7
actually starts but hopefully this is a
sign that we'll get a real trailer soon
where we'll get to see actual scenes you
know not just still photos of what's
going on and we can really start to
speculate from there all right please
like the video if you found it enjoyable
make sure you subscribe to my channel
I'm back I've been gone I've been
traveling I'm actually in the process of
moving to Thailand at the moment I was
in Cambodia for a while so hopefully
I'll have more time to upload videos in
the coming month
we're almost at 28,000 so the book
giveaway still going on if you subscribe
and comment on this video you'll
automatically be entered in the contest
up for the 20th anniversary of George RR
Martin's a Game of Thrones Edition when
I hit 28,000 which is coming soon we
will definitely pick a winner from all
the different videos and comments that
we have since we started if you want
some spoilers about what we know already
from the set you can check my spoilers
playlist and I have a bunch of season 7
videos that aren't spoiler related to
please check those out thanks for
watching I'll talk to you soon
[Music]